hi everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show we're outside the
studio with distribute c.e.o adam chap
Nick we had a wonderful where do you
interview with him the atom is here to
tell us the maximum benefit to
crowdfunding I'm curious what that is
okay so here's the deal everybody going
to talk to you about crowdfunding right
so it's called crowdfunding and my
assertion is that it should be called
something else because everybody thinks
that the maximum benefit of crowdfunding
is correspondent right get your money
and that's true that's a benefit and
it's a big benefit and it's important
right but there's also a wholly
unappreciated sort of dynamic that
happens when you crowdfund okay backing
up the old way the old way of
distributing the old way of raising
money before crowdfunding existed you
know thousands of days ago right was you
would have two ways that you could get
an audience to raise their hand that
they're a fan of yours right there was
buy the DVD where we talk about films
now okay either buy the DVD or go to
theater right and in those two ways it
was binary and themselves whether they
would raise their hand they would either
buy it or they would not buy it so you
would make your film for two years right
and you might tell your audience that is
coming there's going to be a way you can
help us out just when the DVD comes or
thin theaters and go buy that ticket or
buy that DVD and then when it happens
they can either pay ten bucks for the
the ticket to the theater or nothing or
they can pay 20 bucks from the DVD or
not pay that's it so there are three
kinds of audience members right there is
a first kind that is the person who
might have heard about the film might
have been interested
Phil maybe you had something on the web
maybe there was an ad and they're like
okay uh I think I was seen that film but
just on the merits of the film what they
heard they'll go okay kind of one kind
number two is I don't know about this
film but I like Karen I like her style I
like her work I will see this movie
because I like that other things she did
so are their fans of you and they're not
so sure about the movie but they'll go
because of you that's kind to write then
there's kind of a 3 which is I don't
care what you do I'm giving you money to
do it I'm gonna help you do it I'm gonna
come doing I'm your mother and your
brother I'm your husband your son I you
know whatever those are your fanatical
unconditional helpers okay so you got
one two and three right the old way you
didn't know which was which you couldn't
get in touch you can differentiate your
fan base you didn't know some people
just came because they wanted to see the
film some people came because they saw
your old film and some people came
because they would do anything you tell
them right so in the new way oh and
finally those three people all had one
option they could either buy it or not
buy it so if they kind of wanted to see
it but weren't sure then they bought
they just pay ten bucks if they really
wanted to see it they pay ten bucks if
they were crazy about you and totally
would see anything you did they pay ten
books now they might pay ten bucks twice
and by someone else a ticketed okay 10
times you get some 100 people pickups
whatever you know by a bunch of DVDs for
people but they only could do that thing
right the revolution of crowdfunding and
again I think it recalled something else
is that now you can pull all of those
people all the way into your process
starting the moment you think I should
make a movie right and so now you go out
to your immediate community and that of
course includes the number three is your
mom your sister your brother whatever it
might include your number tubes right
which are people who saw your other
films so you have a list it probably
could include number one because through
doing your other things you have some
people who might be interested in the
film you're just thinking right but now
what you're offering isn't hey I'm going
to make this movie in some day pay me
ten bucks to go see see the theater or
give me 20 bucks for DVD now what you're
suddenly doing is you're
sealing all of the value in the creation
of the artist artistic piece there's
value all the way from the moment you
start thinking about it to the moment
you have that DVD or the tour the ticket
right and that value exists in people's
interest in the subject their interest
in you or they're just fanatical support
of any of those the subject or you or
your career so now what you can do is
when you have the idea you say hey I'm
thinking of making a romance in Italy
okay and it's going to be about two old
people there senior sis so I'm really
excited and so you start sharing that in
your social network now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say anybody who
wants to be involved in this way or that
way or the other way can by sharing with
me something you have which is maybe
money or time and in exchange I'm going
to give you the experience of creation
of that thing that you look everybody
who's a fan of romance movies everybody
who's a fan of Italy movies everybody's
a fan of movies about senior citizens
and of course everyone who's a fan of me
right so you can give perks based on the
experience of creation so you can say
hey we're going to have an opportunity
you can you can get in communication
with people about what should the film
be about I have this idea and that idea
you can start communicating with all
these people you can start offering hey
if you want your name to be the name of
the you know hotel that the the main
characters have dinner at it'll cost 150
bucks you can come on the set you can
hang out people start to get excited and
be involved then what you start to do is
do the process of you also there's also
backing up there's also ways that you
can offer an experience of meeting you
and meeting all the other people
involved maybe there's fans of the
actors maybe there's people you're going
to shoot on location in Italy maybe you
can say for this amount of money join us
on location in Florence and is it that
you know that cost you two thousand
bucks be charged eight thousand bucks
maybe people really love you and it has
nothing to do with the movie but they
you so you say hey I'm gonna cook you
dinner and that's 600 bucks whatever
picking up the point is that what taps
into is human beings desire to be
involved in an artistic endeavor that
takes years but they don't have ears
they might be an accountant or a lawyer
or you know they are a mom and they just
made that choice but they want to touch
the filmmaking process and they want to
touch the people they're fans of and
they can pay for it and they will
because before all they could do is pay
ten bucks to go to a theater right or 20
bucks to buy DVD but now they can pay
more and they can have their their name
involved they can be involved with
someone they love they can be involved
with the whole process of movie making
more specific kinds of movie making and
so what that does at the end of the day
after you've figured out all those
things you can offer and as a perk and
get all these people involved is you
move people who are casually interested
the number ones into number three's
right where they are crazy about you
because they're invested in the film
they have their name on the hotel they
were on set they know all the actors
they know the guy who does craft
services this is their movie and so what
happens is by the time that you get to
the end of production which in the old
days was where you would start even
trying to find audience what do you have
you have all of these fans first of all
who never would have even been involved
with you then you have of those fans a
giant number of number ones which would
have been maybe I'll see the movie
they're shifted over to I'm a wild and
rabid fan of you like your mother and
what happens then the day that you
release they're all ready they're locked
and loaded not just to buy the ticket
which they would have done but to
evangelize about the film this is their
film so suddenly you don't just have
your network you don't just have your
list from your old movie you don't just
have your actors lists you have all of
the lists of all of the people that ever
got involved in the whole two years of
your pre-production production post
production that have been paying for the
opportunity to do it so you have a new
army of evangelist for your film the day
it comes out into distribution that have
paid you for the opportunity to be there
that is the revolutionary benefit of
crowdfunding